-I'm here with
Scarlett Johansson right there!
It's like
a show from the future.
This is so wild.
We're about to play
"The Mimic Challenge."
Here we go.
-♪ Mimic Challenge ♪
♪ Mimic, Mimic Challenge,
yeah ♪
All right, bud.
Here's how it works.
We're gonna take turns making
noises with different objects,
and the other person
has to immediately
match that sound as precisely
as they can into the microphone.
-Now, how do you know --
how do you know if you won?
Like, what's the --
-Audience response?
-Okay, fair enough.
You're right.
[ Laughter ]
-Since you're my guest,
you're gonna make
the first noise,
and I will mimic your noise.
-Okay.
I have all these props
over here,
so this is the first one.
-Okay.
-I've never done these.
I don't know
what kind of noises these make.
-I don't even know what that is.
-Bear with me.
[ Laughter ]
What does it look like?
♪♪
-Uh...
A thermometer?
[ Laughter ]
-It's a thermometer.
Okay.
[ Plastic crinkling ]
Erh! Erh!
Errrrrr!
[ Laughter ]
Errrrr-rr-rr-rr!
All right.
That was okay.
Thank you.
Now, oh, here we go.
This is good.
Now it's your turn to mimic.
-Oh, no.
-Okay. Ready?
[ Lettuce crunching ]
-I'm supposed to make
that sound with my voice?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
Yep.
-Ch-cha-koo-tuh!
[ Laughter ]
Ckk-ckk-ckk!
-Oh, my God!
Nailed it!
[ Ding! ]
[ Laughs ]
You nailed it!
Oh, my gosh.
-It's uncanny.
-No, it's so good.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
-All right, I got this.
-Ooh, I like that guy.
-"Squeeze the Jabber Ball."
[ Jabber Ball squeak ]
[ Laughter ]
-Okay.
Rrr-eeee-uh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Ding! ]
-Not bad?
Wow.
I'm actually
the voice of that doll.
[ Laughter ]
For years, yeah.
Okay.
Oh, this one is --
It's a very odd thing.
An otamatone,
this thing is called.
All right,
let me show you what it does.
You press the sides, and its
mouth opens a little bit.
[ High-pitched squeaking ]
-Ee-eeeeeeeee!
-[ Laughs ]
[ Ding! ]
All right.
You have another career.
You have a whole nother career
in doing this.
-Ee-eeeeeeeee!
-Oh, my God.
-Is that better?
-Yeah, I feel like
all these dogs
are just gonna start
running to the studio.
[ Laughter ]
Ee-eeeee!
All right.
-Is that right?
Whoa!
[ Laughter ]
-Wow! It gets bigger.
Oh, my God.
That's a --
That's a vuvuzela.
-Excusez-moi?
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
This is fantastic.
I love these things.
They were banned at, like,
all these football games,
soccer games,
'cause they were too annoying.
-And we're about
to find out why.
[ Vuvuzela blowing ]
-Oh, gosh.
-Is that right?
-All right, let me try.
Pbbbbht!
Pffbbbbhhht!
[ Ding! ]
Pfffbbbbbbbbhhht!
-Whoa!
-Pfffbbbbbbbbhhht!
Pfffbbbbbbbbhhht!
-Very nice.
-All right, Scarlett,
I think you're
gonna do this one.
This one's gonna be good.
[ Whipped cream spraying ]
-Cwwwkkkkk!
-Whoa! I thought
that was really happening!
That one's actually amazing.
I thought I was still putting
the whipped cream out.
Fantastic.
-[ Laughs ]
-I'm saving that
for after the show, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-To put it on ice cream?
-[ Chuckles ] Sure.
[ Laughter ]
[ Noisemaker cranking ]
-Uh-h-h-h-h-h-h-h-h!
[ Applause ]
[ Ding! ]
[ Noisemaker slowly cranking ]
Uh-h-h-h-h-h-h-h.
[ Laughter ]
It's like, a-a-a-all right,
all right, all right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
All right, last one here.
All right. Ready?
All right, here --
it's a little...
[ Porcupine toy chittering ]
-Wee-ee-ee, boo-wee-ee-ee!
[ Laughter ]
-Wow. That's how a professional
does it right there.
My thanks to Scarlett Johansson!
"Sing 2" is in theaters
everywhere December 22nd.
[ Cheers and applause ]
2-2-2.